[Musik]
fünf jahre lang habe ich aus dem
südlichen afrika berichtet
[Musik]
ich war im busch unterwegs habe wilde
tiere aus nächster nähe erlebt und die
schönheit des kontinents gesehen
[Musik]
ich war mal politischen umbrüchen dabei
zum beispiel beim machtwechsel in
simbabwe doch was mich am meisten
beeindruckt hat waren die begegnungen
mit den menschen im südlichen afrika
denn die imponieren mir oft mit gut
erfindungsgeist oder schlicht mit ihrer
lebensfreude selbst in zeiten großer
schwierigkeiten
[Musik]
atemberaubende momente habe ich in
sambia erlebt
in kazan kann nationalpark bin ich einem
der großen rätsel der natur auf der spur
irgendetwas lockt sie an genau diesen
ort jahr für jahr
millionen von flughunden versammeln sich
in einem kleinen wald in sambia es ist
die größte sorge tierwanderung auf
unserem planeten
[Musik]
ich bin unterwegs an diesem magischen
ort im kaiserpark eine gruppe von
wissenschaftlern aus deutschland hat
mich eingeladen ich darf dabei sein wenn
sie versuchen dieses große rätsel
afrikas zu lösen
viele sind ist glaube ich
die tatsache dass wir hier nur
eineinhalb bis zwei monate auftauchen
und keine ahnung woher sie kommen wohin
sie ziehen
dann sehen wir sie und wir hören sie
denn sie sind mächtig laut
auch riechen können wir sie denn sie
stinken auch ein bisschen das ist der
kot der flughunde erklären mir diener
dächern und martin wikelski die tiere
fressen früchte und das ist eine
mögliche erklärung für ihre mysteriöse
wanderung
wenn die regenzeit so über den kontinent
wandert dann entstehen überall so lokale
explosionen von früchten und wir
vermuten dass sie den folgen aus der
vermutung soll gewissheit werden heute
nacht wollen die forscher deshalb einige
der tiere einfangen
wer sein licht nicht braucht schaltet es
bitte aus sagt dina dass man die
flughunde sollen die falle nicht schon
beim aufbau entdecken es ist kurz nach
zwei uhr morgens die wissenschaftler und
ihr team spannen ein großes netz auf es
muss stehen bevor die tiere es im
tageslicht sehen können flughunde sind
zwar nachts aktiv doch sie orientieren
sich mit augen und geruchssinn welche
ordnung wie andere fledertiere haben sie
nicht also wir müssen das netz immer vom
boden weg halten damit das oben ganz
gerade hängt damit die fledermäuse das
nicht sehen das heißt absolute ruhe kein
licht
deshalb jetzt nur noch nachtsichtgerät
im dunkeln verlassen die flughunde ihre
schlafbäume und suchen nach nahrung
erst zwei stunden später haben die
wissenschaftler glück vier tiere sind
ins netz gegangen
schließlich landen sie hier in jedem
säckchen ein flughund
inzwischen dämmert der morgen die nadeln
und martin wikelski bringen sender an
den tieren an sie sind nur wenige gramm
schwer so wollen sie den flug und rätsel
auf den grund gehen erklären die beiden
mehr vor allem der frage woher sie
kommen und warum
die flughunde wir nennen sie so weiß ich
auch ein bisschen die kleine hunde
aussehen obwohl wir natürlich keine sind
und ich darf diese hier jetzt frei
lassen
so klein ist der wald der flughunde für
ein paar wochen heimat für millionen
doch dieser lebensraum ist bedroht
ich treffe die wildhüter david mobiler
und cala sa cala sie sind für den schutz
der tiere verantwortlich und wollen wir
zeigen wie die flughunde im wald den tag
verbringen
tageslicht bedeutet für sie eigentlich
schlafenszeit doch ein paar sind immer
wach erklären mir die wildhüter falls
ein adler oder ein anderer raubvogel
auftaucht
dann zeigen wir mobiler und klar war wo
die noch viel größere gefahr für die
flughunde lauert wilderer legen immer
wieder feuer im schlaf wald denn weniger
bäume bedeuten mehr gras von das hilft
dem illegalen jäger die es auf antilopen
abgesehen haben die werden durch das
gras angelockt und sind im offenen land
ein leichteres ziel
manche wilderer sind grausame kriminelle
die schießen auf uns noch bevor wir sie
sehen erzählt mir mou viana und zeigt
seine wunden das ist eines der risiken
meines jobs mio
mittlerweile ist es abend und die
flughunde gehen wieder auf futtersuche
ich bin zurück bei den wissenschaftlern
sie sind gespannt auf die ersten signale
von den flug und sendern dann hoffen sie
auf ihren karten die flugrouten zu sehen
die der ganz großen wanderung und die
der nächtlichen futter flüge
das rätsel der flughunde zu lösen könnte
auch beim schutz der tiere helfen beim
kampf um den erhalt der afrikanischen
wildnis und der wird überall auf dem
kontinent geführt
zum beispiel weiter im süden in
südafrika
in der nähe von clark stop treffe ich
eine tierärztin die mit sehr
außergewöhnlichen mitteln gegen wilderer
kämpft
schlafmittel große portionen um große
tiere lahmzulegen die ärztin michael
otto zeigt uns die patronen für ihr
betäubungsgewehr jede steht für ein
nashorn dem sie heute das horn abnehmen
will
ich orientiere mich an durchschnitts
tier nehme aber unterschiedlich große
patronen mit erklärt mir die ärztin ich
sehe dass das tier untergewichtig ist
dann habe ich die passende niedrigere
dosis zu hat
es ist kurz nach sonnenaufgang und noch
eisig kalt ich fahre raus mit dem ranger
team und ärztin mische wir müssen nicht
lange suchen nach den nashörnern sie
leben hier hinter zäunen und es sind
viele sehr viele bei unserem besuch war
es die größte nashorn zucht der welt mit
rund 1500 tieren hier nehmen sie ihnen
die hörner ab weil sie hoffen dass sie
so vorbilder an sicher sind
so fährt ist einer der ranger als
kundschafter unterwegs
er berichtet uns dass er ein tier
entdeckt hat dessen horn lang genug ist
für die ernte so nennen sie das hier
michael otto bringt ihr gewehr im
anschlag
der schuss klingt wenig spektakulär und
er wirkt nicht sofort
die hörner vorsorglich abzusägen sei er
eigentlich zuwider sagt michel doch in
manchen kulturen gilt das horn als
heilmittel mit dem sich großes geld
machen lässt wenn der betäubungspfeil
sitzt dann warten wir erst einmal und
halten abstand sagt michael jagen den
tieren nicht hinterher um deren stress
so gering wie möglich zu halten
nach sechs minuten wird das nashorn
schläfrig erst abstand halten dann dem
tier ganz nahe kommen es könnte sich
beim fallen verletzten deshalb müssen
ihm die ranger dabei helfen und jetzt
dürfen auch wir näher heran
alle zwei jahre neben michelle und ihre
kollegen den tieren ihr horn ab sie
sägen und es riecht ähnlich wie
verbranntes haar selbst noch da wo wir
gerade stehen
sicherheitsleute überwachen alles denn
die wertvolle ernte könnte bewaffnete
räuber anlocken damit das nashorn nicht
blutet muss ein stumpf von zehn
zentimetern bleiben das tier wird nicht
verletzt und das horn wächst nach wilder
töten die tiere nur deshalb weil sie es
eilig haben das ist es also das horn um
das sich alles dreht nichts besonderes
eigentlich denn es besteht aus keratin
genauso wie fingernägel und doch auf dem
schwarzmarkt kostet es zehntausende euro
und deshalb vielen nashörnern das leben
waffen zu tragen und hörner abzusägen
michael otto und ihr team sehen sich
dazu gezwungen durch erbarmungslose
kriminelle die selbst schwer bewaffnet
sind
diesmal müssen die ranger ein jungtier
von der ärztin fernhalten denn das ruft
verzweifelt nach seiner betagten mutter
doch auch hier gibt es kein pardon das
horn muss ab gerade muttertiere will man
hier nicht an die wilderer verlieren
michael otto nutzt die gelegenheit und
prüft ob die mutter genug milch für das
baby hat
das schmeckt wie zucker was er erklärt
sie uns probiert doch mal dann zeigt uns
das team seine bisherige ausbeute 9
hörner in drei stunden ihr wert
mindestens
150.000 euro die züchter würden die
ernte am liebsten ins ausland verkaufen
und so den illegalen markt austrocknen
doch das ist nicht erlaubt wenn wir zum
beispiel jedes jahr sechs tonnen legales
nason in den vietnamesischen markt
pumpen dann die wilderei zu nehmen oder
abnehmen fahrt der besitzer der farm ich
bin mir sicher dass sie dann abnehmen
wird
michelle weg das tier nun mit einem
aufputschmittel mit nur noch ganz wenig
horn so hofft sie ist es nun sicherer
das große geld mit der wilderei machen
übrigens meist geschäftsleute aus dem
ausland die die in deren auftrag auf die
jagd nach maß an angehen tun das oft
weil sie bitter arm sind und sich nicht
anders zu helfen wissen
nördlich von südafrika in malawi ist die
armut besonders groß
im ort kalender moto erfahre ich wie die
note das leben junger frauen zerstört
es war fast hatte die entschied dass das
mädchen heiraten und zu ihrem ehemann
ziehen muss damals war werfer gerade 15
jahre alt den mann hat sie nicht geliebt
und die heirat nicht gewollt als ich sie
treffe ist dass zwei jahre her und
bürger lebt wieder bei ihrer tante ihre
eltern sind beide gestorben was tante
erklärt mir sie habe keine andere wahl
gehabt als das mädchen zu verheiraten
ich musste heiraten weil wir arm sind
erklärt mir auch besser selbst meine
tante meinte wenn ich einen ehemann habe
dann geht es uns allen vielleicht besser
dann kam dieser mann und meine tante
zwang mich mit ihm zu gehen
hier in karaj intermoto besitzen die
meisten nicht viel was man hatte ein
fahrrad mit dem er einen transportdienst
betrieb und etwas geld verdiente das
machte ihn so attraktiv
jetzt lebt dörfer ausgerechnet wieder
bei ihrer tante der frau die sie in die
ehe zwang und wie die tante erklärt
steht sie noch heute zu ihrer
entscheidung
ich hatte damals noch acht andere kinder
zu versorgen verteidigt sie sich und
mein mann ist gestorben heutzutage
braucht man geld um ein kind
großzuziehen vor allem wenn es auch zur
schule geht und ich ich habe schlicht
nichts
armut bis der hauptgrund warum junge
mädchen verheiratet werden und malawi
ist eines der ärmsten länder der welt
nun aber treffe ich jemanden der die
mädchen davor bewahren will den
häuptling der hier jetzt eine frau ist
für riesa katja moto sie kämpft gegen
die kinder hochzeiten hatte ehe von
golfer annulliert und die von über 3000
anderen mädchen viele feinde hat sie
sich damit gemacht vor allem bei manchen
männlichen häuptlingen
willst du bald sterben so haben sie mich
bedroht
ich sagte nur wenn er mich umbringen
wollte dann wartet bis ich meine arbeit
hier beendet habe danach könnt ihr
machen was ihr wollt doch wenn ihr mich
tötet dann bin ich bei gott und ihr geht
direkt in die hölle
hopp jüngste riesa hat auch diese
frauengruppe gegründet die ein maisfeld
bewirtschaftet wie die frauen ihr
erklären geht die ernte an die besonders
armen familien im dorf auch das soll
helfen im kampf gegen die kinder
hochzeiten manchmal sind die lösungen
für probleme viel einfacher als gedacht
ein großes maisfeld wie dieses hier
schon ist das dorf nicht mehr ganz so
arm und schon gibt es für eine familie
kaum noch einen grund die tochter jugend
zu verheiraten doch wo die not groß ist
erscheint die zweck heirat wie eine
lösung oft aber bringt sie großes leid
sowie für moussa andrea sie ist 15 jahre
alt und schon zwei jahre verheiratet sie
hat ein baby und die geschichte dieser
schwangerschaft ist besonders verstörend
ich bin mit einer sozialarbeiterin
gekommen was muss anna uns erzählt kann
ich kaum glauben sie ist opfer einer
anderen alten tradition geworden die
heute noch praktiziert wird
meine familie ist arm erklärt sie mir
und deshalb dachte ich es ist gut wenn
ich heirate aber ich wurde nicht
schwanger da sagte mein ehemann er werde
einen anderen mann bringen der mich
schwängern wird mein mann hat damit
gedroht er werde sonst eine andere frau
heiraten und mich wieder nach hause
schicken
fünfmal hat moser mit dem fremden mann
geschlafen weil die familie ihres
ehemannes es so wollte um dessen ehre zu
retten sie haben den fremden mann sogar
dafür bezahlt
er ist einer dieser männer die man in
malawi kennen nennt erika nie war
kurz vor meiner ankunft in malawi hatte
er in einem fernsehinterview offen
zugegeben dass er gegen geld mit
minderjährigen mädchen schläft und das
obwohl er aids hat
[Musik]
es sind die eltern die auf mich zukommen
und mich dann bezahlen sagt er in dem
aufsehen erregenden interview
mittlerweile allerdings ist es besser
für mich das ritual im geheimen zu
vollziehen
anni waging dafür ins gefängnis
mir ist es daraufhin nicht mehr gelungen
eine sogenannte hyäne zum interview zu
überreden
ich treffe wie der bürger
deren leben hat sich völlig verändert
seit sie geschieden ist geht sie wieder
zur schule ihr ehemann wollte das nicht
sah sie lieber zu hause am herd geld für
die schule hat servers familie
eigentlich nicht sie kann nur deshalb
hier lernen weil häuptlings theresa die
schulgebühren und die bücher bezahlt die
schule und das lernen ist das was besser
in ihrer ehe meisten vermisst hat sie
ist glücklich dass sie nun nachholen
kann was sie in zwei jahren verpasst hat
ihre tante unterstützt das auch wenn sie
dabei nicht nur an ihre nichte denkt
[Musik]
wenn bürger eine gute ausbildung hat und
einen job bekommt dann wird sich auch
die situation unserer familie verbessern
hofft sie ich würde mich freuen wenn wir
ein besseres haus bauen könnten denn
hier können wir nachts oft nicht
schlafen weil es hineinregnet
wörter allerdings macht schon pläne die
sie weg aus ihrem heimatdorf führen
würden nach der schule will sie
krankenschwester werden und vor allem
eines als frau ein selbstständiges leben
führen
für menschen aus malawi und anderen
ländern der region ist der ort an dem
sie ihr glück machen wollen südafrika
viele landen zuerst im township soweto
und dort nicht unbedingt in besseren
lebensumständen
es ist nicht viel zu sehen durch die
kuchen box eine echte taucherbrille
können die beiden sich nicht leisten an
einem fluss in der nähe sowie tus
kräftig markus solo und seinen freund zu
die show porsche logo
sie hoffen geld zu finden münzen die ins
wasser geworfen wurden als opfer für die
ahnen
glück soll das an diesem fluss bringen
die beiden zeigen uns wie sie mit dem
tauchen ihren lebensunterhalt verdienen
[Applaus]
ich fische das geld mit den händen
wieder raus sagt markus ok zulu manchmal
kann ich es nur fühlen wenn es sich rund
anfühlt dann sehe ich es mir genauer an
und wenn ich glück habe dann ist es ein
fünf rand stück
jeden tag kommen die beiden an den fluss
sie sind arbeitslos und brauchen
dringend geld doch sie haben auch angst
vor dem fluch der ahnen
denn der gp song fluss gilt als
heiligtum überall am ufer versammeln
sich menschen um den vorfahren
opfergaben dazu bringen
so wie diese gruppe aus dem
nahegelegenen so bieten traditionelle
heiler und ihre gemeinde hier wollen sie
mit dem namen sprechen
[Musik]
für ein gespräch mit den vorfahren kann
es viele gründe geben man bittet um
gesundheit und beruflichen erfolg oder
um glück in der liebe
opfergaben helfen dabei bier für die
vorfahren ist eine möglichkeit erklärt
mir die heilerin ich soll es einfach
hineinschütten
der fluss zeit der draht ins jenseits
und mit bargeld könne man die allen
besonders günstig stimmen
wir müssen geld hinein werfen erklärt
die heilerin denn wir müssen die ahnen
die den fluss besitzen um erlaubnis
bitten ihr wasser zu benutzen
und diesmal machen sie besonders
ausführlich gebrauch vom wasser eine
junge frau erhält im heiligen fluss den
rituellen segen danach darf auch sie
sich heilerin nennen
was marco suppe und zu die so tun nennen
manche hier fräbel sie selbst so sagen
sie mir sind hin und hergerissen
zwischen dem respekt für die tradition
und der tatsache dass die schlicht geld
brauchen
jetzt musst du es auch mal ausprobieren
sagt marco sog doch obwohl er mir seine
kuchen box aus borgt finde ich nichts
[Musik]
auch die beiden haben es heute nicht
leicht das wasser ist diesmal besonders
trüb gerade einmal 24 rand kommen
zusammen umgerechnet nicht einmal zwei
euro
doch die beiden hoffen auf das was nun
flussaufwärts passiert
[Musik]
an das geld das die leute hier hinein
werfen kommen sie heute nicht heran doch
die gemeinde opfert auch hühner und die
werden mit dem fluss fortgespült die
heilerin allerdings warnt davor
opfergaben wieder herauszufischen
[Musik]
für den der das tut bringt das unglück
niemand sollte das tun erklärt sie mir
denn geld das mit hinein werfen oder was
immer es sonst ist all das ist für die
ahnen bestimmt und gehört niemandem von
uns lebenden es sollte deshalb im wasser
bleiben
dieses huhn allerdings landet in den
fängen von marcus sorg er muss nicht
lange überlegen ob er zugreift oder
nicht das huhn sei schließlich frisch
und die lösung seiner probleme sagt er
und auch was die armen betrifft hat er
sich eine erklärung zurechtgelegt
ich bin hungrig meint er und den einen
gefällt töten nur um des tötens willen
sicher nicht das ist doch schlicht mord
ich nehme das huhn mit nach hause und
entweder ich verkaufe es oder ich es
selbst denn ich bin hungrig
heute will er das huhn selbst essen
zusammen mit ein paar nachbarn in soweto
mit etwas toastbrot wird daraus eine
tages mal zeit für sie alle und auch ich
bin eingeladen
hier im township hört man beim grillen
übrigens gerne hausmusik oder den mit
dem hip hop verwandten kräuter
das ist der sound in den straßen sowie
tus ein paar blöcke weiter aber treffe
ich eine band die das ändern will
[Musik]
es gab niemanden vor uns wir sind die
erste black metal band in der geschichte
so wehtut
ich bin mit heavy metal groß geworden
und habe metal schon in der grundschule
gehört
die meisten hier verstehen uns nicht für
die ist das einfach nur gruselige musik
die gitarre im gepäck nicht appelle und
dem wie somit in eine der bars um die
ecke es ist der typische platz um in
soweto den samstag zu verbringen und
natürlich darf auch ein riesiger grill
mit saftigen steaks nicht fehlen
nur die musik die die beiden mögen die
bekommen sie hier nicht
[Musik]
ein konzert ihrer band wer hier und
denkbar sagen sie mir
die leute würden aufstehen gehen und
vielleicht nie wieder kommen erklärt
miersch tempi so augenzwinkernd oder sie
bringen sich gegenseitig um
doch aufgeben wollen sie so schnell
nicht proben für die aufnahmen des
ersten albums ihrer band demokraten
im inneren der tribüne des lokalen
stadions befindet sich der proberaum
ich und meine kamera kollege kevin
stevens sind eingeladen er soll
schlagzeug spielen und ich pass bei
einer jam session mit der band
das gaspedal verklemmt ständig sagt
gewinn aber dafür ist die boden tom eine
echte boden denn die steht direkt auf
dem boden ganz ohne stände
[Applaus]
dann geht es los
für bessere instrumente fehlt der band
das geld und so muss auch eines der
becken ohne stativ auskommen
[Musik]
sehr gut
jam session mit musiker der in südafrika
haben großartig aber ich hätte nie
erwartet dass es sein muss macht
schließlich
[Musik]
die mutter von sängers denn wieso steht
er auf aber doch heute sind die jungs
bei ihr zu gast und sie muss sich deren
musikalische vorbilder anhören
die britische band saxon zb
[Musik]
[Applaus]
als er noch hier gewohnt hat habe ich
ihm eine hütte im garten gebaut sagt
stemper sus mutter seine musik war mir
einfach zu laut also musste er raus
im hinterhof eines nachbarhauses aber
finden sie ein paar musikalische
verbündete
konzert in soweto auf einem mini
festival rock und erst recht heavy rock
sind unter den meisten schwarzen
afrikaner nicht sehr populär und so bin
ich hier nicht der einzige weiße der
eigens fürs konzert ins township
gekommen ist
[Musik]
afrikanisches der sound nicht sagt sie
manche afrikaner sagen diese musik ist
böse ich aber finde sie hat etwas
befreiendes und was dich befreit bringt
dich näher zu gott also habe ich hier
eine göttlich schöne zeit
gegen neue dinge rittes immer klischees
und tabus geben meint er und das ist
nicht in ordnung die menschen sollten
mehr offenheit zeigen
so wie du selbst ist sehr
klischeebehaftet die meisten verknüpfen
es mit kriminalität gewalt und armut
dabei gibt es in südafrikas größtem
township längst auch vergleichsweise
wohlhabende einwohner viele von ihnen
unterstützen ihre armen nachbarn und
manche pflegen unerwartete hobbys
es ist sonntagmorgen und die jungs von
soweto käfer club machen ihre wagen für
eine spritztour klar dass deutsche
automobil erbe wird hier gepflegt das
heute ausgerechnet ein deutscher
reporter vorbeischaut passt da natürlich
gut
welches baujahr frage ich
1967 sagt sie es wie im logo stolz ob er
den käfer im originalzustand bekommen
hat will ich wissen das lenkrad war
original sagt sie diese ablage hier
unten fehlte das radio ist ein modernes
aber sonst ist jetzt alles original
die mitglieder des käfer clubs sind
software entwickler oder
unternehmensberater zählen hier also
klar zur oberschicht für seinen grünen
vw hat sich marko basa bango einen neuen
motor geleistet
der neue motor ist von nissan und hat
eine wasserkühlung erklärt er mir die
original vw motoren sind öl gekühlt
meiner ist viel zuverlässiger ich kann
viel länger 120 fahren ohne dass der
motor überhitzt
[Musik]
und dann geht es los
ich darf in the swiss großmutter
mitfahren so nennt er seinen roten käfer
[Musik]
also das hier ist für mich eine echte
zeitreise denn das letzte mal dass ich
in einem auto saß wie diesem hier da war
ich glaube ich noch nicht mal in der
grundschule mein vater hatte einen käfer
und der rat genau so rot wie der von
sich
[Musik]
die spritztour heute ist mehr als nur
vergnügen sie führt nach clip town in
eines der ärmsten viertel so wehtut
hier kennt man die jungs vom käfer club
schon und heute haben sie besondere
ladung an bord sie wollen nicht warten
bis eine große hilfsorganisation den
armen hier hilft sie haben in ihrer
eigenen vergleichsweise wohlhabenden
nachbarschaft kleiderspenden gesammelt
von den kindern hier werden sie mit der
nationalhymne begrüßt und der andrang
ist groß
[Musik]
danach springt nicht jeder der wagen
gleich wieder an und anschieben müssen
wir ausgerechnet den grünen käfer mit
dem angeblich so zuverlässigen
austauschmotor
so klischeebeladen wie soweto ist in
südafrika auch kapstadt am südlichsten
zipfel des kontinents
touristenmagnet einerseits andererseits
eine der kriminellen hotspots des landes
manche sagen hier herrscht krieg
dutzende tote monat für monat
etliche gangs kämpfen um die
vorherrschaft in den armen vierteln
kapstadt
es geht vor allem um die kontrolle des
drogenmarkt um das geschäft mit crystal
meth und heroin
[Musik]
[Applaus]
einer der gefährlichsten plätze der welt
liegt ganz nahe am tafelberg und den
touristenattraktionen der stadt
li wei und seine großmutter haben mich
auf den friedhof mitgenommen jelic
levi's vater begraben der wurde
erschossen weil er sich weigerte
mitglied der lokalen gang zu werden fünf
jahre alt war li wei damals
ich hörte die schüsse erinnert er sich
dann kamen leute zum haus meiner mutter
gerannt und sagten dass mein vater
erschossen wurde
mein sohn acardo hatte mir sogar vorher
gesagt dass sie ihn ermorden wollen
erzählt mir lieber als großmutter ich
habe ihn nicht ernst genommen denn er
selbst war so ein friedfertiger mensch
damals sagte er mir mutter wenn mir
etwas passieren sollte dann vergiss
bitte nicht dass ich nie mitglied dieser
gang wurde
al kado hätte nicht sterben müssen sagt
seine familie anderswo auf der welt
hätte er die polizei um hilfe bitten
können hier aber so erklären sie mir
habe die polizei den kampf um recht und
ordnung längst aufgegeben
mit einer spezialsoftware wollen deshalb
sie für sicherheit sorgen der örtliche
pastor craven engel und sein team sie
zeigen mir das system überall in ihrem
viertel haben sie mikrofone und kameras
installiert zu sehen und hören sie
sofort wenn es wieder eine schießerei
gibt etwa dreimal am tag passieren dass
auf die polizei warten sie dann nicht
sie rücken lieber selbst aus und haben
ihre ganz eigene strategie es geht nicht
darum jemanden festzunehmen erklärt mir
der pastor sie kommen viel zu schnell
wieder frei und selbst im gefängnis
steuern sie noch die gewalt in unserem
viertel was wirklich hilft ist das
verhalten der gangster zu ändern
sie gehen dorthin wo geschossen wird und
versuchen eine friedliche lösung
auszuhandeln
heute ist es ruhig auf der straße der
pastor hat einen waffenstillstand
erreicht für diesen teil des viertels
zwei tage hält er schon
als wir zusammen unterwegs sind sehe ich
wie viel respekt er genießt vor allem
weil fast alle in seinem team früher
selbst schwer kriminell waren wilfried
mckay zum beispiel zwölf jahre war im
gefängnis schon mit 14 besaß er eine
pistole raubüberfälle waren seine
spezialität bis er beschloss sein leben
zu ändern
als mein sohn auf die welt kam hatte ich
nur noch einen gedanken ein guter vater
zu sein erklärt er mir und jetzt will
ich auch ein vater für andere sein für
die kinder auf der straße
sagt die waffen schweigen gehen die
leute wieder auf die straße auch die
kinder viele von ihnen waren aus angst
nicht mehr zur schule gegangen und heute
haben der pastor und sein team wieder
ein wichtiges treffen
in seinem schlafzimmer empfängt sie
einer der bosse der lokalen gang er
nennt sich lord und er sagte mir er habe
kein problem damit gefilmt zu werden
immer wieder betont er wie gut er mit
dem pastor zusammenarbeite die polizei
dagegen so sagte er genieße hier keinen
respekt dann macht er einen vorschlag
den ich aus dem mund eines gangsters
nicht erwartet hätte
in anderen ländern gibt es doch die
todesstrafe sagt er wir brauchen sie
hier auch nur dann haben die menschen
angst davor jemanden zu töten
plötzlich vor dem haus polizei doch laut
überrascht mich mit gelassenheit er
beendet unser treffen in aller ruhe ganz
so als habe er schon vorher gewusst dass
die polizisten nach wenigen minuten
wieder abfahren werden
auf einer düne vor den toren der stadt
treffe ich die die schutz vor leuten wie
lord suchen
kriminelle die aus ihren gangs
aussteigen wollen und jetzt hier leben
sie alle wurden schon als teenager zu
verbrechern mit 13 oder 14 jahren manche
von ihnen wurden zu mördern und nie
dafür verurteilt
die warnow williams will trotzdem mit
mir sprechen doch nicht über details
seiner geschichte vor allem nicht
darüber ob und wie oft er schon getötet
hat
vor den polizisten hatte ich jedenfalls
keine angst sagt er mir einige von ihnen
sind selbst mitglieder der gangs dube
gehst heute einen mord und schon morgen
kommst du wieder aus dem gefängnis
wie viel an der geschichte dran ist ist
schwer zu beurteilen
angst haben für war nun die anderen
jedenfalls vor allem vor den bossen
ihrer gangs fern von ihnen lernen sie
deshalb hier in diesem ausstiegs projekt
das gärtnern und manche von ihnen
erstmals lesen und schreiben auch levi's
großmutter hat damit begonnen etwas für
eine lebenswertere nachbarschaft zu tun
jeden tag gibt sie vor ihrem haus an die
nachbarn kostenlos essen aus die spende
kommt von einem lokalen geschäftsmann
die idee die not zu lindern die straße
zu beleben und so kriminalität zu
verhindern
eines tages allerdings standen in der
schlange auch mitglieder der gang die
meinen sohn umbrachte erzählt er will
mir ausgerechnet seine witwe gab ihnen
essen aus und begann zu weinen ich habe
ihr gesagt sie soll einfach weitermachen
das war hart für uns aber uns blieb
nichts anderes übrig
wir müssen das tun wir leben hier
zusammen die gangster sind teil von uns
wir müssen das tun
eine zweite chance also für die mörder
aus der nachbarschaft
eine zweite chance auch für cembalo
williams der bandenkrieg in kapstadt
werde noch in 100 jahren nicht enden
sagte mir er aber werde in diesem krieg
nicht mehr kämpfen
auch südafrikas nachbarland namibia
zieht viele touristen an
dort in der endlosen steppe in der nähe
von solitaire begleite ich zwei männer
bei ihrer arbeit in der einsamkeit
ihr arbeitstag beginnt mit dem ersten
licht der sonne
es könne nicht früh genug losgehen sagen
mehr andrew korte und p2
jetzt sei es schließlich noch schön kühl
bei 25 grad bald aber werde die sonne
erbarmungslos brennen
wochen lang leben die beiden zusammen
auf engstem raum mitten in der
abgeschiedenheit der steppe namibias um
die straßen hier in schuss zu halten
der nächste ort wo wir wasser bekommen
können ist sehr weit entfernt erklärt
mir ende deshalb müssen wir regelmäßig
die vorräte prüfen wir haben noch genug
für heute und morgen aber dann müssen
wir den tank auffüllen
auch die essensvorräte müssen sie gut
einteilen der reiss ist aus sagt händel
und auch das dosengemüse
doch die beiden kommen nur langsam voran
und sehen oft tagelang kein dorf und
keinen laden
[Musik]
die beiden männer sind eines der teams
die landesweit versuchen die straßen
befahrbar zu halten im auftrag der
namibischen regierung und es gibt eine
klare arbeitsteilung in rekord ist der
der planiert und in jedem team gibt es
einen assistenten wie p2p
der bewacht so lange den mobilen
männerhaushalt
vor allem abends muss ich aufpassen
erzählt er mir oft kommen hyänen und
suchen knochen die wir wegwerfen oder
interessieren sich für unsere vorräte
neulich saß ich hier als ich plötzlich
geräusche hörte ich habe die
taschenlampe an gemacht und da war die
hier eine ganz nah schaut mich an und
rennt noch nicht einmal weg
viele straßen in namibia sehen so aus
wie diese staubige pisten die schnell
durch spurrillen sehr holprig werden
wenn nicht en vogue orte oder einer
seiner kollegen alles wieder schön platt
macht
[Musik]
für die atemberaubende landschaft hat
andrew kein auge und auch nicht für die
wilden tiere die abgeschiedenheit
bedeutet für ihn vor allem eines sagte
mir auf sich allein gestellt zu sein
wenn es schwierigkeiten gibt so wie
heute
[Musik]
der kühler leckt es ist mittags um halb
eins und die hitze nun am größten bei 47
grad der motor ist heiß gelaufen und das
kühlwasser wird knapp die beiden männer
versuchen hilfe von einem mechaniker zu
bekommen doch es gibt hier keinen
telefon empfangen
es bleibt andrew nichts anderes übrig
als nach einer pause weiter zu fahren
nun mit offener motorhaube und in der
hoffnung dass die luftkühlung erst
einmal ausreichen wird
es ist später nachmittag geworden wie
jeden tag ist nun bad boy an der reihe
in der hitze der wohl härteste teil des
jobs er muss nun zu fuß die strecke ab
gehen und sich um die steine kümmern die
beim flanieren liegen geblieben sind
vielleicht sollte ich bald den
führerschein machen meint pete dann kann
ich stattdessen in dem lenkrad sitzen
kollege andrew ist in der zwischenzeit
weiter gefahren und erreicht endlich
solitär
es ist der einzige ort im umkreis von 80
kilometern
eine handvoll häuser rund um eine
tankstelle auch eine werkstatt gibt es
hier die morgen wieder öffnen wird
[Musik]
in einem kleinen laden kann andrew die
essensvorräte aufstocken und wasser für
den kühler besorgen
am abend schlagen andrew und pete ihr
lager auf nach zehn stunden planieren
drei wochen werden sie gemeinsam
unterwegs sein erst dann dürfen sie für
fünf tage nach hause ihre familien sehen
sie kaum
es ist trotzdem ein schöner job sagt
andrew wir machen gute arbeit und
wenigstens am abend kann ich mich mit
jemandem unterhalten bei einer tasse tee
am feuer
der motor hat durchgehalten die beiden
haben neue vorräte und hyänen haben
bisher nichts davon gestohlen
das so sagen die beiden mir zum abschied
sei das was sie einen erfolgreichen tag
nennen
[Musik]